we start today with Donald Trump's CNN
Town Hall we are going to talk about how
CNN handled it we will talk about
reaction to the town hall from Trump
supporters we will talk about reaction
to the town hall from Republicans and
Democrats in elected office and from
other networks but we have to start with
the town hall itself which was two hours
of trump lying uncontrollably calling
the host Caitlin Collins nasty and
telling the same corrosive Greatest Hits
detrimental to American democracy that
we have seen him tell for years now with
some pushback from Caitlin Collins but a
structure that was completely unprepared
for the absurdity and Insanity of the
event at the very top level MSNBC put
together this sort of highlight uh list
which included Trump continuing to say
say he really won 2020. saying that e
Gene Carroll made up a fake story and is
a whack job remember a jury found that
Trump sexually assaulted her called the
moderator Caitlyn Collins a nasty person
complimented Vladimir Putin refused to
side with Ukraine in that invasion of
Ukraine by Russia defended keeping
classified documents at Mar-A-Lago
pushed Republicans to default on the U.S
debt and said he was inclined to Pardon
a bunch of the January 6th rioters we're
talking about criminals let's get right
into it because there is just so I can't
cover even everything that was lied
about because there were so many lies
but let's start Trump found liable of
sexual assault the day before and then
the next day gets a prime time it might
have been a one hour now I don't
remember if it was one or two hours I
watched it in an accelerated format
after the fact standing ovations from a
sycophant audience and Trump arguably
admitting to criminality during this
event Trump asked those classified
documents did you show them to anyone
and Trump says not really which I think
means yes he did when it comes to your
documents did you ever show those
classified documents to anyone not
really I would have the right to by the
way they would Declassified after not
that I can think of let me just tell you
I have the absolute right to do whatever
I want with him now understand not
really isn't no and immediately saying
not really but I could definitely do it
if I wanted to sounds like he is saying
yes another one of the most notable
moments was when he called Caitlin
Collins a nasty person now when I do my
analysis of how this was handled you can
simultaneously realize Caitlyn Collins
tried to do a good job and when she
pressed Trump he insulted her but also
the way that this was generally handled
by CNN was a disaster this is sort of
the epitome of that when she actually
tries to press Trump he just insults her
why you held on to those documents when
you knew the federal government was
seeking them and then had given you a
subpoena to return are you ready are you
ready can I talk yeah what's your answer
can I do you mind I would like for you
to answer that question okay it's very
simple to answer that's why I asked it
it's very simple that you're a nasty
person I'll tell you
and of course the sycophant crowd cheers
attack think about this this event
embodies the downfall of Journalism but
in more than one way
it's the downfall of Journalism in that
CNN was in way over its head and
completely unprepared structurally to
handle the uncontrollable lies flowing
out of Trump's mouth like projectile
vomiting they were unprepared to do that
that's a problem right in journalism but
also it's the continued attacks on
journalism where when you attack the
moderator who's doing their job or
trying to
your supporters cheer we Trump's
insulting the person asking questions
really sad on many many levels the
topics came up related to the 2020
election and Caitlyn Collins again she's
trying tries to confront Trump with the
reality that the things he's saying even
Republicans say aren't true about the
2020 election and he just steamrolls
right past never had a pay before we
nobody can afford to continue to pay
what's happening with energy but we were
energy independent we were getting out
of Afghanistan with strength and with
dignity and instead we got out we looked
like fools probably the most
embarrassing moment in the history of
our country we have a lot of questions
about the economy and foreign policy
tonight but but what you just said there
Republican officials debunked those
claims about fraudulent ballots we want
to give you a chance tonight who
Republican officials in Georgia and
every single state there is no your own
election officials Mr President so we
wanted to be afraid to take on the issue
but we have a big problem in this
country we have we have elections that
were horrible if you look at what
happened in Pennsylvania Philadelphia if
you look at what happened in Detroit
Michigan this is all debunked lies
understand that if you look at what
happened in Atlanta
millions of votes and all you have to do
is take a look at government cameras
you'll see them people going to 28
different voting booths to vote to put
in seven ballots a piece
that none of that happened because
because there is no evidence that your
own election officials testified to and
have said that Republicans in these
states did this in Georgia there were
multiple recounts including a hand
recount we have questions about the
claims that you're making tonight from
voters on this topic I want to bring in
Scott Dustin from Concord he works in
all right and then this guy we're not
going to play it but this guy then asked
if Trump is going to stop all of this
stuff about 2020 and Trump basically
responded well if there's no more fraud
then I'll stop talking about them the
topic of documents did come back up
Donald Trump claimed Obama took
documents as well and Caitlin Collins
says Obama did not take documents jack
is not criminal I took the documents I'm
allowed to you know who else took them
Obama took them Nixon took them
oh he didn't the difference the
difference
[Applause]
more than anybody is Joe Biden he has
1800 boxes
[Applause]
and nobody talks about him now these are
all lies and again Caitlyn Collins is
trying Trump is totally steamrolling her
in absolutely every way here they then
uh bring up the Insurrection the riots
January 6 2021 Trump says Nancy Pelosi
is to blame Caitlin Collins tries to
interject about Trump's continued lies
about ten thousand National Guard troops
soldiers Etc and Trump just keeps going
and going and going
oh boy
looks like we have a bit of a glitch
here with this clip but let's see if we
can fix it for everybody here we go we
can go sentence after sentence after
sentence of things I said and things I
put out one of the big problems was that
Nancy Pelosi crazy Nancy is a
affectionately call her crazy Nancy
Pelosi and the mayor of Washington were
in charge as you know of security and
they did not do the adjustment
well I offered them National Guard I
said we'll give you soldiers we'll give
you a National Guard Trump did not offer
Trump asked for soldiers to protect him
that's the incredible thing it's an it's
an unbelievable
complete rewriting of History blaming
people whose responsibility is not what
Trump claims is their responsibility and
then we find out Trump was worried about
his own safety he wanted soldiers there
to protect him give you whatever you
want and they turned me down why she
turned me during excuse me she turned me
down in writing they turned me down but
you're acting secretary Chris Miller at
the time he says you never gave
of order to to deploy the National Guard
but when it came to that day just the
opposite Heath Miller wrote a book and
he's a fantastic guy and he was ready to
go they turned him down if you these are
all lies and then maybe one of the most
horrifying aspects to this and again
with a sycophant crowd like this if the
crowd's cheering that's a moment you
want to zoom in on because Trump's
probably saying something horrible and
indeed Donald Trump says he will pardon
a large number of the alleged
insurrectionists and convicted
insurrectionists and what they've done
and I love that question because what
they've done to so many people is
nothing nothing and then what they've
done to these people they've persecuted
these people and yeah my my answer is I
am most likely if I get in I will most
likely I would say it will be a large
portion of them you know
they did a very
if the crowd's cheering it's probably a
really bad moment and that alone Trump's
saying I am going to mass pardon
criminals who were rioting on my behalf
put everything else aside put the rest
of the Town Hall put everything aside
that alone is a great reason not to vote
for Donald Trump when Caitlyn Collins
brings up Mike Pence Mike Pence trumps
former Vice President says Trump
endangered my life that day with what he
did and what he incited uh will you
apologize and Trump says Ah I don't
really think I I didn't he did some
Pence did something wrong by not holding
up the certification of Joe Biden but
one person who was at the Capitol that
day as you know was your vice president
Mike Pence who says that you endangered
his life on that day I don't think he
was in any danger Mr President do you
feel that you owe him an apology no
because he did something wrong he should
have put the votes back to the state
legislatures and I think we would have
had a different outcome I really do
crowd's cheering when the crowd cheered
it was a signal that this is one of the
crazier things that Donald Trump is
saying of course Mike Pence did not have
the authority or ability or right or
permission call whatever you want he did
not have the ability to reject the
election of Joe Biden and to somehow try
to stuff Trump into the Oval Office for
four more years then the topic of e Gene
Carroll came up now I want you to
remember that the day before this town
hall a jury found Trump liable civilly
for the sexual assault and defamation of
Eugene Carroll for Trump's assault on
her in the 1990s in a Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in Manhattan Trump
brings up that e Gene Carroll had a pet
named the vagina and that the judge
wouldn't let that be part of the trial
I'm not kidding folks it's 20 23. former
president running again this is what
he's talking about a dog
or her cat was named vagina the judge
wasn't allowed to put that in all of
these things he but with her they could
put in anything access College majority
of nine people who found you liable of
sexual abuse do you think that that will
deter women from voting for you no I
don't think so because I think the whole
thing
just so you understand ready
I never met this woman I never saw this
woman he never saw her I I don't believe
a word he's saying and then Trump
actually goes into a detailed story
about the circumstances I think I just
lost the light in my suit that was weird
uh goes into a detailed we'll get that
fixed up
he tells a story about what's being said
happened and it's one of the most
bizarre moments of the entire thing I
never met this woman I never saw this
woman this woman said I met her at the
front door of Bergdorf Goodwin which I
rarely go into other than for a couple
of charities
I met her in the front door she was
about 60 years old and this is like 22
23 years ago she was 52. I met her in
the front door at Bergdorf Goodman I was
immediately attracted to her and she was
immediately attracted to me and we
had this great chemistry we're walking
into a crowded department so we had this
great chemistry and a few minutes later
we end up in a a room a dressing room
the crowd laughs and laughs and laughs
they just love it remember Trump's been
found civilly liable for sexual assault
and they're just making fun of the
victim the crowd's loving it everybody's
having a party register
and then she found out there were locks
in the door so she said I found one that
was open she found one she learned this
at trial she found one that was open
what kind of a woman meets somebody and
brings them up and within minutes you're
playing hanky-panky in a dressing room
okay I don't know if he was married then
or not John Johnson I feel sorry for you
John Mr President can I
so think of it an entire crowd on
national TV led by Trump disgustingly
laughing about the sexual assault that
remember it's not a mere allegation now
a jury found Trump liable for that and
the crowd just having a grand old time
Caitlin Collins did ask Trump about the
infamous Access Hollywood tape where
Trump says you can just grab women by
the you know what uh Trump uh Trump
defends it says there's nothing wrong
because he says they let you do it they
let you do it there was a a position of
you from October in it you defended the
comments that you made on that excess
Hollywood tape about being able to grab
women how you want do you stand by those
comments I said if you're famous and
rich or whatever I said but I said of
your star uh
you are and I said women let you I
didn't say you grab I said women let you
know you didn't use that word but if you
look women let you now they said will
you take that back I said look
for a million years this is the way it's
been
I want to be honest this is the way it's
been I can take it back if you'd like to
but if you're a famous person if you're
a star and I'm not referring to myself
I'm saying people that are famous people
that are you are people that are rich
people that are powerful
uh they tend to do pretty well in a lot
of different ways okay
and you would like me to take that back
I can't take it back because it happens
to be true I said it's been true for one
million years million years even before
Homo sapiens it was absolutely the truth
Trump then moving on to what we might
call foreign policy the idea of trump
foreign policy I know it's kind of
laughable but
um given a number of opportunities to
say you know given that Russia invaded
Ukraine and Russia is in the wrong do
you want Ukraine to come out Victorious
from that or do you want Russia to
successfully take over Ukraine Trump
refused to answer that question Nancy
the question here is would you give
Ukraine weapons and funding if you were
I would sit down let me just put it nice
away uh if I'm president I will have
that War settled in one day 24 hours
how would you settle that war in one day
and again the crowd's cheering so it
must be Trump said something stupid and
indeed how on Earth are you going to
settle that in 24 hours
I'll meet with zelinski they both have
weaknesses and they both have strengths
and within 24 hours that war will be
settled it'll be over it'll be
absolutely do you want Ukraine to win
this war
uh I don't think in terms of winning and
losing I think in terms of getting it
settled so we stop killing all these
people and breaking them oh sounds like
a sort of both sides perspective on
something Russia did here
and the crowd loves it
yeah
follow up on that because that's a
really important excuse me
can you say if you want Ukraine or
Russia to win this war
I want everybody to stop dying they're
dying Russians and ukrainians who are
dying like dogs so he refused to answer
that refused to answer that and then
lastly and not surprisingly the cherry
on top Trump refuses to commit to
accepting the results of the 2024
election are you you're are running in
the 2024 race if you are the Republican
nominee and you are in that 2024 race
will you commit tonight to accepting the
results of the 2024 election yeah if I
think it's an honest election absolutely
that means no to accepting the results
of the election regardless of the
outcome the woman answer it again if I
think it's an honest election I would be
honored to and right now we are so far
ahead of both Democrat and Republican
and you know what if I don't win this
country is going to be in big trouble
it's so sad to see what's happening but
it's an honest election correct okay so
not committing to accepting the 2020
horror election results and Trump just
kind of waves off Caitlyn Collins and
the crowd laughs and everybody has a
grand old time this is dangerous
everybody's laughing off the fact that
he did it in 2020 and he's saying he's
going to do it again in 2024 if he loses
he will say that it was rigged
disastrous event for democracy let's now
talk about CNN's role in this
if you deal with anxiety or depression
you may have tried meditation exercise
diet changes therapy all of which are
important things to try there is also a
new treatment that we've been talking
about on the program for years which for
many people has been a game changer and
that is ketamine therapy the research
around ketamine therapy for anxiety and
depression looks very promising which is
why I'm thrilled about our new sponsor
mind Bloom mind Bloom is the leader in
at home ketamine therapy having safely
helped thousands of people with anxiety
and depression it's delivered to your
door it's done from the comfort of your
home and unlike traditional talk therapy
ketamine Works quickly and doesn't have
the unpleasant side effects of
traditional antidepressants in a study
of over 1200 mind Bloom clients 89
reported improve movements in their
anxiety and depression after just two
sessions read about the evidence for
ketamine therapy we've talked about it
on the show it's pretty remarkable stuff
mind Bloom is offering my audience a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program
go to mindbloom.com Pacman use the code
Pacman the link is in the description